[Music]
only the wonderful Nexus could have been
taste me to come it is not easy to make
the interstellar journey what I feel
about it which is that this is the only
conference or gathering I ever go to
we're on the same platform you can find
an admiral and an opera singer what I
really appreciate is having this kind of
interdisciplinary space to talk to
people who are coming for very different
types of movements very different types
disciplines and I think that doesn't
happen enough and that's why the Nexus
is so important to bring people from
different backgrounds different areas
you know just doesn't happen to me very
often to have this kind of range of
perspectives every day something new
happens every week something new happens
and there's barely any time to stop and
think and analyze and digest your being
catapulted into the next event and the
next event that's why we need these
intellectual exchanges how do we
actually make Reason entertaining how do
we speak how many Millennials are there
out there in the darkness one of the
last real place of high level and free
debate and discussion on liberal values
the human being as a dignified being is
defined by certain rights which can be
set down in non abstract terms we have
to start any way of thinking and reject
violence as any means to achieve a civil
human society the idea of a complete
disaster xiety is the worst ideas of
them all because completely just society
is a society where no one can say that
it isn't unjust that this completely
just society is a dictatorship please
join the Nexus Institute
get the bumper sticker join and keep it
alive and because his there's they've so
many interesting ideas and doing a night
like this is completely because of them
Oh